i tried to be as fair as i possibly
could i truly believe not to toot my own
horn okay i think i was fairer to biden
on this thing than just about anyone
else but he is absolutely blowing it
it's outrageous even
even on the left-wing news channels when
the left-wing newscasters are trying to
flack for him even that isn't working
and the guests on those channels are
calling it like it is
i'm curious to hear your reaction
of this consequential speech by the
american president didn't run from it he
owned it he owned his decision he owned
the fact that as he put it the buck
stops with him
i hope he gets to hone their deaths too
i i don't i feel like i watched a
different speech than the rest of you
guys i was appalled
there was such a profound bold face lie
in that speech the idea that we planned
for every contingency i have been
personally trying to tell this
administration since it took office i've
been trying to tell our government for
years that this was coming we sent them
plan after plan on how to evacuate these
people nobody listened to us they didn't
plan for the evacuation of our afghan
wartime allies they're trying to conduct
it now at the 11th hour the thing that
they were most concerned about was with
the optics of a chaotic evacuation well
they got exactly what they were most
concerned of by failing to do what was
right when we could have done it
so this
army veteran a guy who's working on on
these sorts of issues just write to
brian williams's face
i don't know what you're talking about
man i'm appalled and frankly there have
been people in the mainstream media even
on nbc and other left-wing outlets who
have said this is really bad stuff
it was weak sauce in the speech because
he avoided the main question and now
you're seeing
you're seeing this this madness of
stranding thousands of americans there
i'm glad you like that clip you can get
the whole show on apple podcasts spotify
google play stitcher for free it's the
michael knowles show type it in search
it in right now in your podcast app
subscribe
maybe leave a five star review i don't
know i really appreciate it helps us get
around some of the big tech censorship
that occasionally exists around here see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you